let's go so yeah this is a game between
dubo and karyakan
um they're both super grandmasters
uh playing for russia so we can
um imagine a fun battle happening
and this i believe this tournament was
in 2020 and
uh the game this is um this game was
played
during russian championship so it's
gonna be a bunch of fun
let's go so
the first things first how do we feel
about italian
and being played in super high level
i'm not entirely sure i don't know like
for me i feel like
um like especially when it's
the tournament as important as russian
championship and it's like
last round it feels like it needs to be
more and
um for from what we gathered
at this tournament karjakin only needed
to make a draw
and uh then he would be at least tied
for first
and yeah so he he would need this
but uh he's playing duboff so he kind of
got to be careful and he's also black
yeah i mean brian clark i feel ya it's
probably going to be like 30
prep at this point um yeah so
duboff chose a relatively um
less bloody compared to advance
c3 and finally we got
[Music]
juju piano i cannot pronounce
this for my life so you're gonna have to
just laugh along with me for my lack of
pronunciation
of juju piano and i know that's not the
way to pronounce it
i just i've always read it like this and
i could never change it so feel free to
make a mini clip out of this save it as
ranked on whatever you want with it
make sure there's a little laughter next
to it
yeah um so yeah
before we got it i've i'm thinking i've
never played this opening as white i've
played it with d3
few times in a serious game
yeah so with d4 i just always like i've
had this happen to me a lot
as black but i've never really played
this as white so
what do you think b4
anything special about this because
as you can probably recall the main line
is to take over here
check probably bishop d2 nice it's real
so possible
but bishop d2 take and then you take and
the queen gets out of here whoops and
then the queen gets out of here
and that's kind of one of the things
that's always um
you know there but i don't really
i like it's so everybody knows
everything about it
so b4 was somewhat new i'm
thinking have i ever had anybody play
this against me
when i was black and not just in like
blitz game more like
a little serious game at least rated
events
i can't recall if anybody has ever
played this against me
when i play this opening as black so
yeah um so i'm assuming that karjakin
was also a little caught off guard
because this is not one of the main this
is not the main line the main one is
generally taking
i mean also e5 was possible but that's
also transposes to a whole different
world
so now what do you think white should do
i know it's very early if you're on like
move seven but i really want
to know what you think white should do
here white is doing well but
obviously this is prep so
what do you think
castling possible
but if the castle then knight can take
oops knight
can take on e4 and then d5 is coming up
no surprisingly right now we don't want
to castle just yet
yeah we don't want to cast we also don't
want to rush
into taking it because again knight
takes e4 so the biggest problem right
now is this knight takes e4
so let's go ahead and play e5 yeah
exactly let's go ahead play e5
we're attacking this delicious knight if
you try to
move it along and now i get to castle
and next move i can try with d5 and take
here and i have a cool center going on
if you try to play d5 yourself i can
ompus on you
and i could still push over here
and then try to take this well right now
you're attacking my bishop so let's save
the bishop
go for this diagonal and i mean this is
possible but i think um
just castling too early would be a
little
um what's that i want to say
not too cliche too
it kind of makes it so much easier for
black we don't want to make la black's
life easier
so after knight e4 um
if we cast still then there is that d5
right
so let's play bishop d5 ourselves
attacking them lights
you kind of only have one good idea to
do f5 is just
a bunch of different ways of wrong i
could take it over here castle queen
running out of here you're never going
to be able to do shortcast though yeah
no
um i can also just simply castle if i
want to so yeah
no no no no f5 exactly exactly thank you
brian yeah if a castle it would be a
little too passive here so bishop d5
you take i'm gonna have to take and now
we gave up these two beautiful pawns
third one is also on the way potentially
i still haven't really castled i have
peace activity
but that's all i got so how can i use
this piece activity
why to move what should we do
no a bishop of seven it's way too early
we don't really have too many pieces
that can
join this just yet
i agree we should definitely bring in
more pieces to the attack the question
is how
one way is to try and get this guy
involved so yeah i see some people in
the chat they're mentioning bishop g5
and that's exactly what happened in the
game as well when you play bishop g5
now bishop g5 that has bunch of ideas
well i want to eat your queen and i am
offering you the chance to make a
mistake black has two
reasonable moves to do with either
knight e7 or f6 trying to save the queen
f6 doesn't work but it's worth it it's
worth mentioning because
not because i get to take it no no no
but because of gorgeous bishop h4
if i were to take this now you get to
take back
now when i move this away you get to
activate your queen
and then we end up in this position and
then black is just better
um technically i could try to i guess
castle and if you take over here then i
could
throw in a check somewhere here but no
it's not worth it
the problem is with f6 you can simply
play bishop h4
something like queen e7 now it doesn't
work because i simply castle you cannot
open like this is not open and i have
upper hand
i have threats you don't have threats
a lot of the times that the idea of a
threat is much
stronger than execution of the idea
so if you want to threaten
this poor king that's the best way to do
it
instead of just showing your hand to
first too fast for
the poker loving people here i need to
learn poker
i started learning a little and i just
couldn't connect
anyways that's why f6 is not a good
choice
and now if knight e7 happens which is
more desired for black you know black is
karjakin he's a
super grand master kind of like kind of
plain chicken
with opponents now what do you think we
should do as white is it finally time to
put this king in a good place
speaking of good place i like the tv
show
uh having sacrificed this bishop right
now it's
definitely not the right choice but i
i understand that if given the chance we
want to do it if you have the chance to
get
more pieces involved i definitely do
want to do this
i think queen b3 is to a little
premature because you get to castle
two and i still have to castle but then
i have to now be careful of like c6 and
fives queen b3 is too early because you
still can't castle that queen major
doesn't help us
it is time to castle now
if you also castle
now i it's still quite tricky because
black still has these two extra pawns on
cnd that he's taken
but slowly slowly black could be
building up
very slowly again but it's a good chance
so we have to be careful um i would say
maybe right now rookie one
now if you try to play h6 i can
move this bishop away and
try to maybe play b5 so no c6
then eventually i'm gonna eat this bond
so i'm only gonna be down one pawn as
white and i have great piece activity so
at the least
thing at least of all i have a counter
play and counterpoint on its own is
pretty
pretty cool so um
however karjakin did not play castle
just yet
he went there to play h6 okay i wanna
keep this going so i'm gonna keep my
bishop on h4
um and here he castle
okay fine we looked it into this
position if you canceled earlier i
intended to play rookie one anyway so
i'm gonna go ahead and do that
and now black has different options
one of it is this weird a5 it's not that
weird but a5
and you're just trying to like open up
the rook but then it's not really gonna
catch because
you could always just play b5 and then
c6 to play bishop e4 you you know you
hold your own
um and so
let's go back
um all right so
here after rookie one
karjakin was smart he doesn't
necessarily want to you know
play something weird like g5 g5 is
not going to work here and the idea is
that we get to sacrifice
you all are talking about the idea of
sacrifice on f7
but this is much better next move the
queen is jumping this is totally losing
for black now
doesn't matter what you do i will get my
pieces out whoops
sorry not taken there my bad that was a
that was the force of a mouse whoops
ah take just kingish one don't get don't
fall into rabbit holes just
hold with your plan if you try to be all
cute now i can just bring up my queen
uh however if you try to you know
take it's still possible but the problem
is that you know queenish five
doesn't doesn't have that strong impact
it ends up with check and then the queen
can stop you
and if you try to take it takes and you
can still fight
there's like a rookie tree or something
but it's not exactly
the ideal uh black can try
and get away with this as we can see
so yeah that's another part to keep in
mind but yeah the idea of a g5 here does
not work this actually reminds me of the
game i played against jennifer u that
she
really loved g5 different position and
different opening but still
she did a g5 and she got into trouble
that was a beautiful game one of my most
precious themes anyways um queen e8
now what do you think we should do we
try to free the
we tried to free this pin now how do you
think it's going to follow
what do you think we should do as white
probably is finally going to take it
over here so most likely something
related to this poor bishop
i don't think we should allow this
exchange my bishop is much more worth
than your 19 disposition
so yeah let's save the bishop good idea
yep i like it too let's save the bishop
now we are again still two pawns down
my c and d pawn are missing well not
technically saying i gave it
voluntarily um
but that doesn't justify this idea that
just because i'm two pawns don then
uh my position is not good my position
is good
it's i have counter play i have
compensation
and that's good enough the idea is that
i'm most likely going to be able to eat
at least one of these back but
we don't really want to um put too much
pressure in eating ponds
we want to use our peace activity and
the king weakness
and this cool central pawn to go about
it for this game
now having mentioned those black still
needs to activate his pieces
he still needs to get this bishop out
this stroke out and something like d5
doesn't exactly work
because we take it and hello beautiful
night's gonna fall so black tries to
play something like 85 to
you know open up a little bit and here
white does something quite magical
i did not see this move when i was
looking at this game personally
but it makes perfect sense so what do
you think
white should do
black is trying to do stuff in the queen
side don't really care much about the
queen
side so hi i see more people are joining
our
stream welcome
nope not queen d3 not g4 nope not a3
think more related to opponent's king
thank you that's very nice of you i like
my streams too
and i have a cat sleeping on my porch
too he is not
that he went out and he played for about
an hour today so
he's very tired
nope not queen c2 i see what you're
trying to do
oh hey buddy
and crows yeah you guys are thinking
more critically
exactly bishop f6 because you're never
going to take that bishop
if bishop goes to f6 you cannot take it
you take it i'm taking this back first
of all
i'm not technically giving you a bishop
because this night
it will fall and it's
then your rook is going to fall and it's
much more words than just that one
bishop that i
momentarily sacrificed so
black can't take
knowing that black can take this also
means that
sooner or later wyatt is going to bring
the queen
in the game um depending on the rank or
to diagonal
let's see what black does but the idea
is that i'm going to bring this queen in
the game
probably get it somewhere close to here
and that's going to be it for black
so it's very important for us as white
to be able to find the correct way to
get the coin involved
but first things first so black is not
going to be able to take this
but he has uh he has another
i he they're like they're different
moves that are possible here obviously
well one of them is crucially uh
important the other one is just like ah
doable
what do you guys think what is um
the important move that black really
really really should do
there's there are many i agree the ninth
move would be interesting
uh why nice g6
it is black to move so if it was like
the move i would definitely be
doing something with this queen it is
black to move
i agree that this knight most likely got
a move
because um you know if this knight
wasn't here we could potentially try to
take it
so i don't think knight g6 is the way to
go just because
my bishop is here so it's pinning your
pawn so now when i move my queen
it's going to have even a bigger impact
to try to move your king
all right now i can take it over here
you take it well now i'll just take back
he moved the queen
now hello hello whoops
yeah this is so much stronger than
imagined
or even if i want to take it a little
slower
i would just do like a night is for two
if you try to be
cool and take it i can just take back
now this is even with this i hold clear
advantage for white
yeah um the problem is this
pieces you cannot get your pieces
involved but
my pieces are very very involved so
that's why we care so
so so much about peace activity
anywho um knight g6 doesn't exactly work
because it's not really um going
anywhere
how about knight f5 what do we think
about knight f5
any suggestions on what white should do
now
uh colin no there are official
commentary teams
for candidates so i'm not going to be
doing that
anytime soon it feels a little um
too much to like there's every single
channel
right now is talking about candidates so
not today
yeah queen d3 the idea
is when we do this queen d3 if black
wants to be all cute
he can try and push for d5 and this is
actually black's best chance
take and queen d7 and if i try to you
know now it swans to eat my bishop so i
gotta
save the bishop and this is still a
black is holding
black still has an extra pawn the pieces
are
breathing a little bit more so it's as
good
it's a little bit better uh well
actually this is
black's best option but even in this
black doesn't hold advantage it's just
the position is holding there's a very
sad difference between holding advantage
or
just holding the position i feel that
i feel i feel like that for my
tomorrow's example
uh all right so knight f5 would have
been karjakin's best choice but in the
game under pressure
especially last round karjakin is still
in shock of what happened in the opening
so he's trying to
play a little bit more aggressive with
what he's got so
a4 now what shall we do with this bishop
are we gonna take it are we gonna keep
it in this diagonal
i think those are the two valid choices
bishop c2
i don't really um
not exactly because just
it can easily be stopped so i guess
these two choices
which one do we like
yeah i see this suggestion with bishop
c4 i think the
the problem with bishop a4 is again my
g6
and if this knight can get to g6 now he
wants to eat my bishop
and it also wants to bring more pressure
on my pawn and
potentially knight f4 knight e6 it's
gonna try
and be um black is trying really hard to
hold this position
so we don't want that we want to i want
to keep my bishop where it belongs in
this diagonal so bishop c4
dugo was a strong player he found this
move
and now finally black played knight g6
to be fair knight the f5 does not really
work anymore
because i could play queen d3 and if you
go for the same ideas
this doesn't exactly work anymore
because bishop e7
remember the queen uh the last time we
looked at this idea the pawn was on a5
and the bishop was on b3 so the queen
would be defenseless now that's not the
case
if you try to be if you try to tank i'll
take that
i want to eat over here or finally eat
over here oh that's such a
cool position i wish this was my game
anyways yeah so that's kind of the
general idea that's
why a4 was bad you can't you probably
can't really make that distinction so
early on
right now but you don't need to move a4
so that's why i'm a little like uh i
understand it because if
maybe white would be tempted tempted
to eat the pawn but dwight's duboff is
not a kid
well i mean technically he's young but
um but
he's not an inexperienced inexperienced
player he's a very strong grandmaster so
it's not going to just fall for that
little cute pawn on a4 anyways
so bishop c4 knight g6 queen d3
and c card that's also another part
about it
instead of queen going to d3
white has a slightly better move what do
you think is the best move for white
here
queen d3 is perfectly fine but
there is one move that could be played
that's just a tiny bit stronger
what do you think
how can white continue
nobody no suggestions
[Music]
this is not the way to go now there's d5
there's take over here ah
careful nope nope nope maybe knight is
four's
potential um but instead of queen d3
just queen c2
now if you try to play d5 i'll still
take this and probably bishop e6
try and block over here then i could
just eat over here you eat over there
and then i can eat over there oh my god
so many
eating ideas rook d1 yeah then like
instead of queen d3 just queen c2 like a
small improvement compared to queen d3
that is the thing is when you play queen
d3
now black has this d5 you probably take
it then it's gonna be bishop e6 and it's
like
similar plan just as when the queen is
on
c2 the queen is more protected and
less prone to um exchanges
so what do you think white should do
right
now this is also kind of a crazy move so
i'll probably give you guys about 30
seconds or so
what do you think white should do now
taking queendix g6 is definitely
interesting
but do you think it actually works or
are you just saying it because i asked
you to think about this move
okay rook takes e6 could be interesting
but it's definitely too
early it's not the right time
all right so i see more um support for
queen takes g6
anyone wants to be against queen takes
g6
i love this debate
it does work actually um right now queen
g6 works quite beautifully
it's a little weird right it's just
gonna give a queen for two pieces are
you kidding me
but it works very very beautifully
now what do you think black should do
black has to be very careful because
well i'm attacking your queen
and i also have potential for discovery
check so what do you think where do you
think this queen should go
uh well that's the thing black kinda has
to be careful
queen c8 does not really work because of
rookie seven and then
um that's gonna be quite interesting
very close to mate
g8 there should be something here
yeah just move the stroke pretty much
anywhere dirk f7 you just take that back
i could also take a bishop probably king
f8 move this bishop
no this is too great for white worst
like easiest thing i'll just bring my
knights involved
um yeah so no queen ciena is too far
away from the king so it either has to
be
c6 to attack this bishop or f7
so the thing is if whites
sorry if black plays for example queen
c6
now we can do rookie seven if you take
i'll take over there
and take that and um now white has
slight advantage it's not big
but it's still um it's still worth
mentioning
now the thing is after rook takes d6
rook takes c3
is like an extra pawn this um
it's still not really something i would
um you know sacrifice a queen for
but it was a beautiful like this this is
um
this is great chance for white
so however
in the game black played queen f7 i
think queen c6 would have made it a
little um
a little easier to hold because a lot of
things would have to be exchanged
and then we again are back at this idea
of peace activity
we need peace activity if right again
for example if karyakin had played queen
c6
kept the queen active then he could have
easily tried to
enter that end game however queen f7
now what do you think white should do we
don't really have
checks here but we do have the chance to
get the queen back
should we go for it
what i'm kind of referring to is knight
going to e5 to attack the queen
should we yeah so i see a lot of things
okay rook
e4 not really because he takes over here
if you take not on rook takes back now
black has the upper hand
so not tonight's if then not rook e4
but i think knight e5 is worth
mentioning
but 95 again doesn't really work because
take
take king moves and whoops not not there
because then i take it over here
king moves and then this is playable but
again black has the upper hand so not
knight e5
what else do you got i want to eat your
piece so you should most likely move
this right
now it's just a question of where to go
i think the healthiest way to look at it
is delicious pawn i'm hungry let's go
yeah let's go for that after we play
exactly
after we play bishop c3 um we have we
still have
a lot of cool ideas not necessarily 95
ideas but next move if it's white to
move i could want to just play rookie 4
and win the the queen right because now
i'm not losing this bishop my bishop is
safe
so here after uh bishop c3
i didn't completely understand the
computer's recommendation
of bishop takes f2 i didn't really
understand
just king takes king moves away and
rookie one and
i yeah it's just probably to stop 95
ideas but
it didn't really go well for my attitude
and i don't think karjakin liked bishop
f2 either since he played king and
shades now
king is right what shall we do
again keep in mind we've all we've given
up a queen for two pieces
and bunch of peace activity as white so
we should probably
be looking into some
again more peace activity
what suggestions do we have
what do you think we should do here as
white
rook bringing the rook to e1
maybe anything else
anything maybe a little bit more active
i think rocky one is definitely a safe
choice
but we want to maybe something is just a
tad bit more active
ah rookie 7 doesn't really work because
queen takes c4
what else
how about rookie 4 i'm defending my
bishop and my bishop is attacking your
queen
how do we like that
i defend and attack
now if black wants to well
um be cute and take it over here
which i it's
still kind of weird to me because now
there's like queen f5 and yes there are
three pieces
um for a queen
but this that kind of actually makes
sense which
that's what doesn't make sense to me why
this makes sense
and but it's all about peace activity
now
if black were to give up that bishop
black would actually get peace activity
and that's so
weird to me yeah um so
that's why this bishop f2 is constantly
being recommended
however it's a little um out of
our scope so not bishop of two
and karjakin simply just played queen f5
queen f5 is fine just bishop f2
gives it a little bit more like spice i
guess that's that's it
that's the best way to explain because
this bishop it's not like you're it's
not like anything is
right now going to um eat this bishop so
you don't have to give it up but
queen f5 you are definitely um
keeping the peace activity now what do
you think we should do here as white
this is a gorgeous bishop right here
another i got another one staring at
that diagonal too
me too i like it when my bishops are in
the long diagonals it kind of warms my
heart
makes peacey happy too who is sitting
next to the door
and kind of grooming himself
hello
yeah he's been having a little bellyache
recently he keeps
needing to go out to eat grass
if it continues i might have taken to a
vet
now we can do rookie 7 thank you yes
and the idea for q7 is simple i'm hungry
me personally i'm not that hungry i kind
of had a late lunch and i ate so much
yesterday
i kind of went on a chocolate spree i
don't know why i did that
i was stressed for my eggs
but yeah i went on a chocolate spree so
i'm not hungry but
anyways yeah rook e7 let's just go for
the delicious g7 and um
black kind of again this bishop f2
is what's being recommended because now
if you take it now this doesn't work
because hello
queen c2 and i'll pick this guy up you
go here i'll take that
actually i could easily just take this
too um
if you try to you know go back
i'll just eat it then again you're in a
pickle my friend
if you don't take it and play kingish
one now rook g8
but bishop f2 would be a good try
bishop f2 is worth it because three pawn
pre-pawn and the tank take
and white still holds a little bit of
advantage
but um black would at least have
a better try and that's kind of
what matters alrighty
so uh black didn't take that chance and
he simply went for rook g8 now what do
you think we should do is white is it
time to eat that
should we be eating the rook or
should we be bringing in more pieces
yeah it's about time we gotta eat that
uh i wish d7 would work d7 is so
cute but it doesn't really work
unfortunately
so
um after i mean the problem let me try
to be a little bit more
uh specific the problem with d7
is i know what i mean we see what's
happening but
something like c6 something as simple as
just pushing the pawn
kind of stops the plans i feel like d7
would all still be a good fight but
there is we could easily just um
move on with this position too and this
is a better choice
thank you marcin yeah so tanking is a
better choice and then we get to eat
over here
we're not threatening to make a queen
anytime soon but
that idea that constant kind like fear
that black has to deal
with that's kind of cool that's what we
want
all right so d takes c7 now
black went ahead and played queen c2
queen c2
best pull of the position but white
still holds advantage
now the question is how do we continue
we got to be a little careful because my
f2 is under attack and my c3
and depending on where i place my bishop
c7 so
queen c2 has multiple attacking points
so it's important to choose the best way
to go about this
as white
so what do you think what should whites
do
i don't want to lose my bishop so most
likely i'm gonna have to move that
bishop anyways just a matter of
where
and i don't really want to sacrifice no
no taking on g7 is much
much too early we don't want to do that
we don't really have any other pieces to
follow it with
if we had another rook involved another
night involved
maybe i would actually like that yeah
yeah bishop b5 is the best way to go
when you play bishop e5
you kind of have to make a choice you
either going to
lose f2 or c7 because you can't really
hold on to everything and something like
that you just lose c7
so uh i was concerned with bishop here
when you
if you try to take it like could draw
like rook c1 but then again he can take
it over here
and now there's another passport
opportunity and that's really worth it
honestly
um so going back to
my strong lovely pawn let's keep this
pawn
you take it i move it now you go like
attack it now what should we do
this one was also kind of um
just purely weird because it's just one
of those moves that you don't
necessarily think about
and it's not that it's like a
sacrificial or like a cool
move it's just just weird it's kind of
the best way i can explain it
it's like you wish you could bring your
rook but you can't do that just yet
so in order to get the rook involved
what should we do
it's like trying to talk yourself into a
certain
[Music]
move
what do you think should happen
where is the cat the cat is um staring
at the window
very graciously
not necessarily rook d7 again this is
weird so i'm just gonna go ahead with it
this
h3 i just like open some room for my
king to breathe
and that's about it um
after h3 black played king h7
and now what do you think we should do
as white
now my rook has a little bit more free
room so
how can i get it more involved
what do you think we should do as light
what's the problem with trying to move
the stroke
the problem is that if i move the stroke
i'm going to lose this pawn right
not necessarily right now because i have
some suggestions with taking in c8 and
blah blah
but that's the problem right so instead
of having to worry about
when to you know deal with this drug
let's just play a3
i stop you from playing a3 i stop you
from trying to eat my pawn
ah i'll just push the pawn now um
after playing yeah i think a3 would have
been more precise yeah
however well again uh i don't really see
that much of difference
just like when you play a move such as
h3 the next move a3 makes sense you know
in the game uh black simply white simply
just wanted to play rookie one
he didn't really bother him and queen
takes a2 is not a big deal because take
take and then now this is i can just
make a queen
so uh that's not a big deal but uh now
a3 that's kind of what we were worrying
about
because then potential tanks and pawn is
beginning to you know
look all cute so
after a3 now what do you think white
should do
there is still some moves left but
we can all see clearly that white is
indeed better
hello what do you want kitty
ah don't walk on the laptop pc
he made that move i did not make that
move
he she decided to make some moves
who's a big boy all right
um so
here after a3
we do not want to play rxd7 i mean i
guess rook 27 is possible since uh
gmp recommended it with his glorious
pause um no but dirk d7 is definitely
possible but
we are still kind of in the zone of
playing chill being protective for a
phylactic move
oh i'm so bored so king-ish too
um it's just trying to take it step by
step
i'm worried about you pushing to make
your queen and give me check
okay i'm just gonna be chill i'm just
moving my king up
however rook t7 indeed was a better
choice thank you for your recommendation
all right um
after king h2
karjakin played g5 and
now this is another cool suggestion oh
i see there's some farsi in the chat too
now
what do you think white should do all of
our pieces are somewhat involved except
this little dude right
so what do you think we should do with
that do you have any other suggestions
gnpc you want to put the knight
somewhere
who's a big boy who is stealing my mouse
ah can i have my mouse back please
all right let me get them all spent
all right i've been
i have a cat here so life's good
whoa well i guess there goes the answer
so
yep knight d4 it is knight d4 is the
easiest way to
get the knight involved if you try to be
all cute and take it
perfect for me i'm going to take this
back um your queen is kind of like
stuck to my pawn i can easily push this
pawn as well
uh this is just this is so cool it's so
easy
so um karjakin still wants to
you know try his best and push for
trying to hold on to the position create
opportunities for himself and all those
um things that we
want to achieve during a chess game he
still wants those two
just because he has a horse position it
doesn't mean that he should give up
so after knight d4 karyakin followed up
with queen
c4 saving the queen from blast
and still holding this queen responsible
for c8 square
so now what do you think white should do
we still probably want to get this
knight involved because it can still
improve right
so stuff are happening on g7 square so
let's bring the knight
to say hello as well
yep nine to five thank you and i see
there's a
meow meow in the chat i guess that's
move
meowing with the knight i'm not entirely
sure what that is
but i'm good yeah
all right so now knight f5 we are going
to
say hello to opponents king with
blessing from
gmpg here commander rook d7
should have taken his advice seriously
ah that was a big yawn all right so
after knight f5
black is still trying to fight but this
is kind of like a
really really really lost position so
black is just like i'm gonna try and
hope for
eating a rook um
this is really highly unlikely like i
guess the only way that black could
actually
eat the rook is like if white plays
something as weird as like
g7 even bishop g7 works anyways
um burke c1 keep it simple
um i just want to push this pawn make a
coin i just want to eat over here
force you to eat back so i can make it
for you like the idea is simple
um karjakin is still fighting quite
sadly but still trying to
king g6 it's like last resort to try and
kick this knight away
to you know if i move this knights then
my rook is
defenseless what do you think we should
do here this is a very easy move
it's not the only way to win but this is
a very easy move
what do you think should happen
black white to move black has some ideas
black is very lost
first thing i would recommend is to
think about is checks
honestly i think 96 is
alright too knight 36 can be a little
questionable because of bishop d4
[Music]
however
yeah rook g7
yeah rick g7 makes it much easier
after rook g7 if you take it uh perfect
hello my beautiful new queen
still this is under attack the king is
weak and this is like
should be very very winning like as
winning as any major 9 or 10 gets
uh however not strict even if you didn't
want to play rook g7 i guess
something like even if you make a queen
right now that should be fine
you take this i will take
that if you try to take over here i
still have like
g4 but we don't need to you know oh
hello thank you
checkmate but i don't really need to get
into that
if i don't want to rook g7 is another
easy way to win just rook g7 and that's
what happened in the game too
uh karjakin tried to follow with a take
or two
but now this is just like two rooks and
a bishop in exchange for clean and also
this is very
weird out king karjakin still pushing
he's a little hopeful maybe try to push
pawn but this is this is really hopeless
this is
just ouchy check and 38
uh yeah so karyakin
finally had enough and he resigned
black is clearly losing there's not
there's no question in that part of it
a rookie five check is also coming up
checkmate threats
but yeah so this was a very interesting
game
and any questions i do want to share a
little bit more about the game
just the uh dynamic of it because
it was the last run if you have um
russian championship
last year so it was kind of a big deal
it was very memorable
yeah um
so this was a very beautiful game it's
been do both
and karjakin if there are no questions
we're gonna have our favorite segment of
switch to twitch
uh we're gonna go um analyze your games
on twitch um so
you gotta send me some games
uh if there are no questions we will be
doing
that for the rest of the evening so
please go ahead and take a little quick
break
grab tea water hit your little kitty
and join us in about five minutes on
twitch
uh and have your games ready on leeches
to send us
links and yeah it's gonna be great but
yeah this was my last youtube um
youtube the video of
when i'm 22 years old
yeah this is uh this is sad because
i'm gonna be turning 23 soon
all right uh i'll see you guys shortly
on twitch
please join us and send us your games on
leeches